I was going to push you in that
Christmas tree this the last time I can
push you in the Christmas tree
you and I had to hey chat I had to Bo I
was going to
pull you know what come not with your
hip with come on let's reenact it we we
got come on do it in slow motion do it
in slow motion it up do it in slow
motion okay all right I can't I can't
wait to see this all right this is from
two years ago y'all ready
ready
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's a reenactment we it's a reenactment
Fu it's a reenactment I got to come over
here and get it you got to go help him
up Eric put something in them damn toys
you a got it's incred it's impossible
for me to lift the big fella we good we
don't need to go to the board right now
ER better than a boy put something in
these damn toy bues oh there was
something in this one I thought I had a
cushion my neck and my
back come on
Eric you can talk about your yeah I just
but I love my reenactment of Shack that
was that was actually really good it
wasn't good cuz it hurt it actually hurt
yeah I thought I had some there you go
thought I had some presents in them damn
Boxx do we do we have another look at
that by chance I would really I'd love
to see the slow motion the slow-mo of
the slow-mo that would oh here it was
and again the acting shot oh my God that
looks so great
oh I come a long way since
Kazam I guess that was
actually